it's a millionaire theme aller on the
Dave Ramsey show we're interviewing
actual millionaires Ron is we're in the
middle of talking with him in Los
Angeles he's got a net worth of 2.25
million made on average income of
125,000 inherited none of it fifty-four
years old
senior operator at a utility company
business degree and that's about how far
we got into the discussion so Ron tell
tell us how you end up with two million
dollars net worth at 54 years old what
do you tell people that the thing to do
to do that what you do well when I first
started with the company I was with they
had a gentleman explained to me on my
first day of work to contribute into the
retirement program as much as I possibly
could back then it was an esop type
program it wasn't a 401k but when we
rolled into the 401 k's i contributed
and maxed out and also took the maximum
contributions that the company would put
in with it to so that's where most of us
would come from okay so I recommend
doing all that alright so talk to the 25
year old version of you out there I hear
this a lot by the way that uh that
someone grabs a young person by the
scruff of the neck and their office and
says fully funds your 401 K and you'll
be a millionaire someday and some of the
people they do that to listen you were
one of them that guy made you rich he
absolutely didn't to this day I thank
him every day that's pretty cool for
others
you gotta stay on a budget unfortunately
we I was good in the retirement pieces
but I failed in all the other money
situations dramatically until we found
your program a few years ago and we made
some real bonehead moves with money but
the retirement has always been there and
since then we've you know got a good
budget going we what's the what's the
what's the dumbest thing with money
you've ever done but some new cars was
one tried to start up a business with
limited time and limited income to get
it started and which brought us into a
big debt
how many how many new cars have you
bought throughout my life I bought five
new cars one of the first one of that I
kept for 10 years
and then a died on me I had to buy
another vehicle which we bought another
new vehicle which I now have been
driving for 12 years even though they
were new I've been keeping them for a
long time mm-hmm they weren't the best
purchases of my life gotcha okay so debt
did not cause your wealth but instead
caused you a setback is that what you're
saying yeah I truly believe that what I
have now in net worth would probably be
doubled if I would have been smarter on
the other portions of my money life my
staying out of debt for instance show
okay I fan out of debt so what's the
most expensive pair of jeans you ever
bought I'm gonna say it's about 20 bucks
and that pair of jeans still is around
and it's 14 years old okay and what part
does giving play in your financial
equation that is a huge part of our life
I've been contributing to donations or
concerts at companies and and nonprofits
for many years that we really believe in
and trust in but the biggest thing is
that we are free to tithe at least our
10% or more any special contributions
and that's the freest feeling we've had
because in the past when we were in our
financial problems it was difficult to
ties we did it but it was it was always
one of those can we still survive if we
if we did this Ron thank you for sharing
your story you're a great American
success story we appreciate hearing from
you thanks for sharing your your life
with us
you